ouais j'espère bien on va faire une
interview première fois en baisse la
lumière ne bouge pas branding changer de
l'exemple choisi de la magie puisqu'on
comptable bien intérêt ouais c'est vrai
que j'avais l'image des petits moyens
avait déjà gelé serbe s'est élevé à
premier souvenir premier souvenir mais
votre premier souvenir de votre vie
c'est dur mais je ne m'en souviens pas
donc si ça c'est sa relation sexuelle ah
bon c'est ça vous allez trouver en
jouant minutes la mouna oui mais c'était
vous souvenez c'est pas très visible
dans une cage d'escalier mais pas par
les ascenseurs quand on est quand on ne
fait pas exprès je veux dire c'est
beaucoup moins drôle
c'est votre premier objet fétiche tu
peux pas le dire non à l'ascenseur aussi
vraiment oui le premier péché le vol le
vol
ouais je savais ce que c'était c'est le
porte-monnaie de votre mère au début non
non il a piqué un ballon et personne l'a
rattrapé le marquer à l'insee ces
petites voitures neuves way qui de
voitures dernier outil créé le premier
jour à l'école vous en souvenez
très difficile ouais et le premier jour
au stade français je me suis demandé ce
que je fais là j'ai beaucoup nouvelle
t'être nouvel entraîneur nouvelle
président je me suis dit c'est peut-être
pas fils le meilleur choix
le premier rigole enrico c'était qui
votre première idéale vous maintenant
madonna a dit dont madonna votre mari
vous en a voulu
ah oui je sors de madonna s'est pas
l'histoire quand il priait madone
justify my love c'était votre mari
trouve ici une chanson très non mais à
la fin vous savez ce qu'elle a dit non
ce qu'on peut dire ça à la télé nous
français on peut tout dire dans cette
émission on peut tout dire à la fin
l'ifac oui oui l'ex mari était en train
de prier alors il se lève il prend le cd
il le jette par la fenêtre en disant je
ne veux plus jamais entendre parler de
cette femme chez moi à oui les madrigaux
qui passe en twingo
c'était d'éviter l'accident de et j'ai
battu haas a battu premier flirt
ça vous a pas laissé un souvenir
impérissable premiers trous de mémoire
oui bon je me souviens la première fois
avec une fille vous en souvenez là oui
bon d'accord les ricains garçon s'est
très mal passé je suis mal passé à m
vous avez pu recommencer donc les îles
une fois quand même c'est bien il faut
essayer d'être ainsi après il s'appelait
sapé par maman il plaisanté
il est jamais essayé cette mode qui n'a
jamais eu envie d'essayer non non c'est
marrant ça quand ça ici
ouais c'est bien passé non mais j'ai
essayé d'accord et la première fois à
plusieurs reprises mais oui et alors
cette pratique un petit rien ne vaut un
bon sourire tu sors quand même de
résoudre ça lui rappelle de tristes
sympa la même année il ya eu tout son
visage s'est illuminé et les combien de
filles comme garçons de m
trois garçons et deux filles espace
ouais bah ouais à canal c'est tous les
jours non a obtenu un canal quand on
fréquente eyeshield c'est dramatique
ça sent bien les premières cuites nous
l'heureuse douloureuse pastis oui nivet
pastis et un du rose et du pastis ses
connaissances rico à saint tropez l'été
on regarde le 1er juin
la mort 10h30 17h à vous a laissé un
souvenir impérissable
oui très mauvais avant vous ai plus
jamais recommencer
non j'ai marqué contre 105 vous êtes
international de rugby certainement je
me disais aussi première ecstasy jamais
pour ça que vous êtes international de
rugby six premiers millions pas encore
pas encore
vraiment j'ai nos mots nos mamans comme
ça a été très sympathique que je voulais
je vais faire un petit cadeau
ouais c'est le nouvel hymne du stade
français ah oui la 6e seront à avancer
car il sort de chez vous qui avez passé
le stade français c'est qu'ils avaient
relancé à will survive et ça c'est un
original ça va très bien merci beaucoup
lui coûtera en pensant à vous merci que
l'escale dominici avec douche et lumière
pour le match
bon je vais vous dire plus été